obviously I went to Vegas and I went to
twitchcon yeah how was that uh I heard a
lot of talks what talks did you hear
tell me the tales I've just seen I just
saw a bunch of Articles of like what was
happening you know during that time what
was happening uh just a whole slew of
things to too many things in
fact I don't understand this is a dig
or you hear it's not a dig I just like I
just saw a lot of like things that were
picked up by articles said that like y
heard I heard some tea happen man give
me give me the tea it's twitch C of
course tea happen I don't know the
specifics though but I don't know let's
hear from the guy who actually went
there was there uh I don't I mean I was
at my booth the whole time so I didn't
hear anything right so yeah I had a
booth and it was kind of a disaster
really well no full story so I I was
going to do this this video well this
stream where it's going to be like uh
human crane game so like someone could
get in the claw right and then I'd be
like the host and it we'd be streaming
it we'd have all different types of
games and we'd be using the claw in all
different types of ways and there' be
prizes and stuff that people could win
it going to be really fun sure so uh we
we booked this space that was like 30 by
40 square ft which is pretty big yeah um
like 10 x 12 met something like that uh
I don't know what it is in meters 40 in
in uh meters um so yeah and then uh we I
had a production team working on it and
um we were we were trying to get
sponsors for it and we had like one
sponsor who was down uh par shout out to
them sick uh and then um we were going
to get more but it was really tough like
sponsors just didn't want to sponsor
anything twitchcon um and it wasn't just
because it was like ball pit physical
related it was just because like a lot
of sponsors just didn't want to be a
part of twitchcon right um for whatever
reason um and it was really tough and
then I was like okay well I'm going to
lose money but that's fine because I
think it's a really cool idea sure but
then the cost started getting like
really really really like crazy and got
to the point where where I would have
lost like $200 plus
th000 which is like in Vegas yeah so I
threw it all Vegas basically I put it
all on red
anyway um and so I was like okay well I
can't do this anymore I got to pull the
plug problem is I'd already like paid
for certain things like the booth space
I had to lock down MH and that was I'd
already paid for that um and uh I also
wanted to do I also paid had to pay for
some of the creative stuff that we'd
already done so I was already down quite
a lot of money and then I had this space
that I had nothing to do with and I was
like well I should I should do something
with it cuz I feel like I'm going to
twitchcon anyway it would be really sad
if there was just an empty square and I
didn't do anything with it and I was
like okay well the only thing I can
think of that is literally zero staff or
like one staff member um or two at most
is just I'll just do our slpl but in
real life like I'll just have three
white walls and you can come drawing on
it uh cuz I thought okay how it can't be
that expensive to build [__] three
walls um turns out it is [__]
expensive to build three walls at a
convention um there's just so much like
dumbass fees in these convention Halls
that they make you as an exhibitor sign
up to as we found out with Anime Expo um
but as I found out even more so with
this con um like you know when you when
you have the booth we didn't need a
floor for any of it it's just it's just
three walls but they you have to pay for
carpet to be put down and it's like
$10,000 for a carpet to be put down it's
it's [__] yeah it's like what what is
this [__] like gold ass plated carpet
what is this why is it $10,000 it's cuz
it's like union labor and other St pers
Persian carpet it's ridiculous it's so
ridiculous so like there's so many weird
fees and so I ended up building three
White Walls still cost me like 60 Grand
which is CRA three walls which is crazy
but I was like yeah it's insane and I
was like [__] it let's just do it cuz I
I want to do something and I don't care
if I end up losing even more money on
this now cuz I'm already so much money
in the whole [__] it I may as well get
something out of it yeah this got the
same energy as like
gambl G I'm already this that also
happened I was like [__] it let's do
this uh let's [__] build it like
let's just I'll have something cool that
I at least can walk away from and be
like I have something I can stream I
have some kind of content and I the
initial sponsor Pari was still down to
sponsor this so I was like okay let's
let's do this then um and so that was
really I was really grateful they did
that CU I helped kind of fund that and
pay a bit of those costs
so uh yeah we ended up we were like [__]
it let's do it it was going to be like a
a a so you're going to need visuals now
Mudan sorry it was going to be a square
but remove one of the walls so you can
enter through that wall and there'll be
three walls boom boom boom right and it
would have been really cool obviously on
the outside there's only one way to come
in but I I didn't care about that I was
like [__] it like it'll be cool just
have three like walls surrounding you
and it'll look great on the YouTube
thumb thil it be really cool um and then
so I sent off that design and they were
like cool cool yeah we'll get that built
so the day before twitchcon I go to the
con which is all also by the way there's
a [__] nightmare getting my badge at
this Con they should do what ax did I
accom I'm giving credit to ax but they
mail out the badges beforehand yeah yeah
dude it it was like 4 hours for me to
get my badge because everyone was
useless nobody could help me but
apparently my badge had already been
printed which didn't make any sense and
then everyone just kept telling me to go
to someone else it was just such a mess
it was so bad I've by far the worst
badge pickup experience of any con I've
ever had in my life uh please fix that
next time short please it's like
Partners right you're not printing off
that many partner badges why can't you
mail them you know all the the addresses
of the partners because they have to put
the address down for twitch anyway why
can't you just mail these badges off and
just have them there this feels like a
no-brainer uh and avoiding like a bunch
of people and like fan meetups at the
like there no brain anyway y so I go to
the con the day before and I go to I'm
trying to find my booth I don't know
where it is so I'm looking around for
like what is a very white looking booth
and I see like this thing and I'm I'm I
see like the what I think is my booth so
I guess this guy cuz there's a few white
panels on the floor but nothing's been
built yet uh and I asked the guy I'm
like hey uh is this the is this the Sea
Dog Booth he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm like oh cool cool I was like you're
building like a like a square right
without one wall he's like no I was like
what are you building he's like I'm
building a plus I was like a plus what
do you mean you building a plus I was
like I never [__] signed off on a
plus the [__] is this cuz I'm thinking I
only have one camera to timelapse this
yeah how the [__] am I going to like all
four walls of the plus how am I going to
timelapse all of that Sor spat um so I'm
like Jesus Christ I'm like what the [__]
so I call up my I'm like hey what the
[__] happening why are they building a
PL and so apparently what ended up
happening was the middleman we were
using uh just completely didn't forward
the design and then they just ended up
going with just one they made up okay
and I was like this is crazy so they
started building this there was nothing
we could do cuz they didn't have any of
the materials now to build what we
needed to build so I'm sitting there day
one I get there I'm already down 100
plusk on this this idea and then I get
there and they can't even build a
[__] square a blank square and I'm
like holy [__] this is cursed like this
is meant to be the biggest failure of
all time like why is this going so wrong
like I'm being like I'm being punished
for no damn reason at least the
blackjack tables will go great for me
tonight I
hope I'm being I'm being [__] in every
way and so it was just it was I was so
annoyed like that Thursday I was
miserable cuz I was like this is just
going to suck like this like none of
this has gone right like I'm down so
much money with not even three blank
walls to show for it I got a [__]
blank plus to show for it a blank who's
going to who the [__] wants that wait so
the blank plus is that like is it only
one side of the wall could be drawn or
could both it would have been two sides
so you would have two two sides were
branding for the merch and two sides
were white so I asked them I was like
what can uh what can we do with the
materials we have what other shapes can
we do cuz I want as much of this wall
and less branding yeah cuz I want people
to be able to draw I think that was way
cooler for people to be able to do so we
ended up kind of like if you had the
plus like this we kind of turned it like
this so that it was still secure and
then the so it's an X what yeah it's an
X like a really thin X it's a very very
very thin X that still stable stable but
had way more room to draw on um and so
you couldn't see any of The Branding so
I I I must have I don't know how much I
paid for those prints to be branded but
I had to just scrap it because I was
like [__] it I want the wall to be the
focus um and it was yeah it was really
it was really hard cuz I was just like
God damn it like I've sunk so much time
and money into this for it all to go
horribly wrong even when I was like
trying to get something out of it um it
felt like I was being punished for
something I'm sure I'll find out what
this is this sounds like the most
engineering problem I've ever had in my
life it's just like ahuh okay I see
you've uh sent the schematics for a
square with a with a side it's crazy
it's crazy we can do this this is this
is simple there is no possible way you
can [__] this there's no way you can
[__] that up it's so hard to [__] up
building a square I think I could have
built the square give me the materials
in half a day I think I could have done
it should have just gone to the hardware
store just bought some dry wall done
yourself so you know it ended up
happening and I was really kind of
bummed out cuz I was like [__] this is
just going to go wrong and then um that
night uh uh we got lwi and and then we
were like let's going just you know in
Vegas let's go and gamble by the way I
I've been very harsh on gambling I think
that you should never gamble unless
you're within the means to be able to do
it and you should only be losing
whatever you feel comfortable doing it
and I was I had I had a I had an amount
of dollars that I had in cash from
previously visiting Vegas and I was like
I'm only going to use this and if I lose
this I'm done like I'm not I'm not
withdrawing any money U luckily I didn't
do that at all Vegas but the first night
went horribly I just kept losing and I
was like this [__] sucks like I'm
just losing money and everything's going
wrong this is awful and so that day I
was like well at least I'll get 8 hours
of sleep and then I went to bed and I
couldn't sleep so I got three hours of
sleep that night and then had to go like
a Mr Bean episode everything everything
went wrong and then I I was miserable
and so I I had to start the stream the
next day and um I start the stream uh
and my backpack just doesn't work
and I'm like this is [__] hu what
have I done did I run over an orphan at
some point I don't recall this ever
happening what did I do to deserve this
like I feel like something is [__]
with me um and so luckily uh gunrun uh a
good friend of mine was was an owner of
vjo the CEO I asked him for tech support
I was like hey can you help me and so
luckily it was an hour late and I did
people were the con had already opened
the plan was to start the stream before
the con opened
the kind it was of people and I was like
theing I start the I got show the blank
wall we can't ask people like to stop
cuz people would just start walking in
pick up a pen and every's like no um and
so an hour an hour after the con opened
I finally got the [__] stream working
and it was a really fun stream but it
was really tough cuz the lighting was so
bad in the venue you couldn't really see
the drawings very well um so the first
day I stream for like 4 hours it was
really fun and and the wall itself was a
great idea I think it worked really well
it would have worked better if my
initial concept was there cuz that would
have been a lot more fun and I could
have kept track of it a lot more cuz I
had to keep bouncing between the sides
um but it went really well and it was it
was it was a lot of fun I think people
really enjoyed it down the end it kind
of well your definition of worked out
would have to take into everything into
account but I think for the thing itself
the idea was solid like I think it was
really fun um the only thing we had to
keep keep doing the day one people wrote
their name names a lot people were very
uncreative people would just write
things cuz they wanted to do something
and they would put their they'd put
their twitch name be like damn that's
not bad and then I'd come in and be like
what the [__] is this no one no one
gives a [__] and so I would just rub it
out um no
self-promo well it was cuz people were
just writing and there was not a lot of
artwork happening so what we ended up
doing was every day we were going to do
different types of like materials given
but we realized it was just there wasn't
that many drawings we we kind of just
wanted to like just keep rubbing out and
getting rid of the text how many dicks
did you get not that many about to ask
question you think a lot of people were
very worried and I knew that I I knew
that it wasn't going to be that bad like
I knew people weren't going to behave as
you should have just done like a thing
where when someone came up with the pen
you should have just been like no text
well so we did end up writing a sign
saying no only artwork yeah just draw
something yeah and people did start
doing it and especially when I think it
was
because initial early on I didn't stop
people from doing it and then when
people see text they feel more
comfortable writing text but if they saw
only artwork I think people would be way
more hesitant about just writing
something absolutely um so I think if I
was to do it again I would and I think
I'd like to do it again because I think
it was a fun idea obviously I don't need
as big of a space so I think I'd be up
for doing something like that again I
think at at C like twitch con it kind of
works because there's a lot of a lot of
streamers came by and wrote stuff which
was really fun like I think the idea was
really solid I just needed to clean up
the execution and obviously have the
cost way less yeah um and have an actual
and have an actual and have an actual
box and have a square we could have had
half the space and utilized it so much
better and I I would have saved I could
I think I could have done that booth for
like 50k had easily have gotten like one
sponsor in a little bit and that could
have covered all of like the the costs I
would have incurred from doing it and I
think then it would have been a great
success and I think I definitely would
be down for doing something like this
again at twitchcon um cuz I think it it
was really fun when it was working
really well um um the signal wasn't the
best so day two I ended up swapping I
ended up begging gun I was like Hey gun
do you have that because gun gunan has
this phone setup for live streaming
where you can just stream shrait off the
phone oh [__] and it's it's really good
because in low lighting the traditional
streamer setup is really bad but the
phone the Samsung Galaxy phone is so
good and it and it looked so much better
um and so day two and three we had a
phone it looked a lot better but i'
signed up to do this this dumbass twitch
Rivals thing which I shouldn't have
signed up for where it was BAS basically
a uh Apex Legends uh uh like tournament
you lost me right but imagine this
imagine this right imagine that say less
so they have like they have like the two
two Team captains for the 5v5 basketball
competition they got LeBron James on one
team and they got Jimmy Kimmel on the
other team and that's basically how it
was and and except except in in it's a
battle royale and there's there's n
there's like 12 teams all different
basketb pros and then me and so it was
awful I didn't get to play I literally
didn't get to play for 4 hours I had to
sit there and stream it it was so bad um
and the rivals team are very nice and
one of one of them did apologize to me
was like ah sorry about that I was a bit
of a wash I like ah don't worry about it
it's find happens I was very annoyed at
the time though I was like [__] I
shouldn't have done this I knew this was
going to happen because I'm not good at
the game and they made me a captain and
I was like no don't do this put me with
some Pro
please um so so that ended up happening
and then I I didn't get to stream the
booth as much day two but day three it
really came together and we had some
amazing artwork in the end and I got to
do a really fun twitch Rivals with Pete
that and demod Di and five up that was
really fun we got to do like party
animal some physical challenges it was a
really fun TW twitch Rivals event
actually that was much much better than
the other one I think cuz it was all
just like people who were just streamers
who weren't good at any of these things
in particular who just kind of tried to
do it and we won we won the party
animals oh nice yeah Pete popped off
even though he never played it
animal it's kind of like uh do you know
Gang Beasts at all it's kind of like one
of those games where it's like people
just punching and it's all kind of ragd
doll physics and you have to like hit
each other off the stages okay okay oh
we got to play some Gang Beast bro that
game is so fun party an are better Gang
Beast hell yeah okay um and so yeah uh
it ended up it was it was pretty fun uh
for like the work stuff but I I had
signed up to do way too much cuz I did
like did the otk schooled thing saw that
mhm uh wish I won congratulations genius
I there was a there was a dots moment
when we had to do dots andly I'm pretty
good at dots it's like give me a beer
one of the questions one of the
questions and I felt personally attacked
by this they were like what is the best
country to get a hair transplant
in do you know the answer Wales no it's
turkey oh oh yeah right I was like all
right [__] now hit hit the dot hit the
it's a it was hit turkey like dead on oh
hell yeah oh I like damn he knew was
like d easy points easy points cuz you
do dce so much in Japan and in the UK so
I I love doing darts and it was great um
anyway it was fun but I signed up to do
way too much I was like from I was up
from 8 and I I would get back at 700 and
I'd immediately have to go for a dinner
or hang out with people or you know
socialize because that's main thing you
do a little social butterfly you are
well you kind of have to that's the
whole point of going to the con is like
socializing so I I had like a total of
like 12 hours sleep across like 3 days
it was so bad I was dying I think if I
would to do it again I would sign up to
like half the amount of stuff I did uh
it was really fun con I think it was a
great time but man it's dangerous being
in
Vegas so much gambling because there was
the hotel that all the streamers were in
yeah and you would just you would just
walk down the hotel and just walk past
the tables cuz they were right next to
where everyone was walking right so any
people who are staying in this hotel
could probably see all of their favorite
streamers just gambling yeah and you
would walk down always there would be a
group of streamers gambling course there
are course you're in Vegas so yeah it
was it was interesting also Vegas sucks
so much I spending four days in Vegas
made me realize how much I don't like
Vegas um I think two days in Vegas was
Max is what I would like to spend I was
there for a year bro yeah that's [__]
I think like accumulatively day one day
one was kind of like exciting you're
like man we could do anything yeah day
two I was like okay it's kind of fun I'm
kind of getting bored of gambling Satur
Saturday would should be the hype day I
was like okay gambling again oh gambling
again but then everyone be like we're
going to go to the club I'm goingon to
watch Diplo